foreign
we have Claudia in Detroit to start us
off hey Claudia welcome to the show
hi there I want you to know I realized I
have learned much from you and your
father so thank you oh well thank you I
appreciate that
how can we help today George I'm not
ignoring you oh it's fun I was just
enjoying the sentimental moment between
you guys I love it here's my dilemma uh
my mother's 84. she has an 86 000
interest only loan on her home
um I've been trying to help her since my
dad passed six years ago to really be
tight on everything she is tight she is
not a spendthrift but the numbers are
hard and you know with an interest only
the variable rate it we knew it was
coming right we knew it was going to
raise I checked into last year trying to
get it refinanced and the problem was
she couldn't afford a traditional
payment of a you know a true mortgage
so my question is
um should I take money out of my mutual
fund to pay it off
um you know assuming that then of course
I would First Cash Out my emergency fund
and the savings we have
sorry but you can imagine this is
emotional yeah
um
but then I'm like I don't really know
like what would be the tax ramifications
for me like if I take that money out
then where do I go from there
um
is that going to affect me I talked to
her today I said Mom
I could you know you and I could do
doordash where I like I'm truly doing it
but I'm I'm driving she's with me so
she's gonna have it on her income level
right she's 84. yeah
uh I've got three brothers they all help
they all are very good they're or United
but at the same time
you know I don't know what to do I don't
even know what the smartest thing I'm so
sorry Claudia well number one putting
yourself in a terrible financial
position is not the solution so we have
to find more options here you looked
into refinancing is there could could we
downsize her is there an apartment or
condo that we could move her into with a
much more reasonable mortgage that then
maybe the kids can help
I you couldn't find anything cheaper
than what she's paying in the interest
only I mean right now it's like even
though it went up it's 4 38. they went
from 274 in January to now 438 but
obviously they raised rates again
yesterday
so
the problem is with the interest-only
mortgage she's never going to touch the
principal
yeah I believe me I know that so it
seems like it's a good number but we're
not making any progress at all how is
she eating Claudia like where is she
getting where does she have money to
live off of
Social Security in a very small like 260
dollar uh pension okay
so what does that add up to per month so
we're talking 25.50 a month okay
what other bills does she have
so she does have the car and I try to
not get her into a new lease but
um we couldn't find something that would
work for her
and you know how often is she driving
around at 84.
every day I would say she goes somewhere
every day you know like doctor or
grocery store or hanging out with
friends what's she doing church right
grocery store doctor Church she goes and
walks she's very conscious about staying
as healthy
and
active
I think we got to get out of this lease
does she have any other debt
no other debt okay
what if we could the kids could scrape
together and buy her a used car and we
get out of this lease situation to free
up some of that income and see what she
could afford then as far as housing
yeah that would probably be a good idea
I wish we would have done it before
but yeah that might work because at this
point we we can't just let her do
whatever she wants while we Finance it
because she's broke
and so this isn't she's not that way I
mean my parents are godly people but
they had a major flaw as in money and
they laid up treasure for us in heaven
where it will never be destroyed
and I get totally what you're saying
there's no excuse making going on here
but but taking out a lease at 84 is not
helping anyone especially herself does
she know that this lease is hurting her
yeah I don't think you know you wouldn't
be able to have a conversation without
her knowing that yeah she she knows they
screwed up major on finances
that's okay and we're not here to shame
her I'm just here to help her get out of
this lease to free up her income because
that payment could be helping her afford
housing
right
so what is that payment every month
the lease payment is uh let's see here
the 314 a month so that extra 314 coming
in every month would that help her
afford a mortgage
if we switch to a conventional mortgage
eyes
eighty six thousand dollars
what's the equity in the home
is she sold it today how much how much
could she sell it for today on Zillow it
says 130 I would say we clear it by 120
for sure that's what I say
man Claudia I mean that just given her
situation everything yeah um how
terrible this mortgage is
um I mean I I would be tempted just to
sell get her out and free up her life
out of this terrible mortgage
uh yeah fix the car situation and then
look to see okay yeah what is something
just and again you know she's
um you know she's in her early 80s so
she still could have a great 10 years
left right another decade if she's
healthy
um so finding something for okay we have
10 years left you know just just as a um
as a math equation to say okay what's a
what's a small condo nothing fancy
anything in-law suite with one of the
kids if she's able-bodied yeah driving
around because because Claudia yes
cashing out any retirement on your end
would not be smart wiping out your
emergency funds and putting your family
at rest which is so generous and I hear
your heart in it is so good but it
doesn't help the situation because she's
still gonna have this terrible loan
still attached to her that she's gonna
have to make payments on but it's not
even hitting the principal so if I were
her and you guys I would I'd sell
everything the car and the house get the
equity and go find something small